[Música]
hola esto es aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente yo soy natalia cabrera y esto
es lo que veremos hoy
empezamos en sudamérica en brasil en el
campamento indígena más grande de la
historia del país llegaron a brasilia
desde lejanas aldeas amazónicas para
protestar contra el presidente ya ir
bolsonaro que pretende legalizar la
extracción de ahorros y la deforestación
en las reservas indígenas allí
estuvieron nuestras corresponsales y
luego vamos al norte del continente
nueva york- fue sacudida por un nuevo
tiroteo en plena hora pico en el
subterráneo justo un día después de que
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
firmara una orden ejecutiva para regular
las llamadas armas fantasma imposibles
de rastrear y bajamos hasta la frontera
entre méxico y eeuu un lugar en el que
regularmente personas de distintas
nacionalidades se apilan esperando
cruzar a territorio estadounidense con
la invasión rusa ucrania muchos son
ucranianos que huyen de las atrocidades
también rusos que no están de acuerdo
con el accionar del presidente vladimir
putin
y vamos de inmediato a brasil para
nuestra historia principal en brasilia
se ha levantado el campamento indígena
más grande del país más de 14 etnias se
han reunido para rechazar el paquete de
leyes que califican como de la
destrucción son normativas del
presidente ya ir bolsonaro que prevén la
legalización de la actividad minera en
tierras protegidas
bolsonaro quien aspira a la reelección
en los comicios de octubre de 2022
intenta aprovechar los últimos meses de
su mandato para ganar el apoyo de los
empresarios agrarios el reportaje desde
nuestras enviadas especiales al corazón
del campamento indígena
desde el inicio de abril más de 8 mil
indígenas acampan en esta explanada bajo
un sol de justicia aguantando
chaparrones de lluvia
están aquí para protestar contra el
gobierno evolucionado gracias a
donaciones de ongs y de personas físicas
esta es nuestra base nuestra delegación
del pueblo calla bovino desde el estado
de matto grosso
bet took me to quiere es el nieto del
cacique raoni que debido a su edad
avanzada no pudo viajar a brasilia este
joven tiene la enorme responsabilidad de
representar al pueblo kayapó uno de los
más afectados por la producción de soja
la ganadería y la extracción ilegal de
oro
mostrado ni suele decir que es muy
difícil luchar la solución pasa por
aumentar nuestra población para que
podamos defender nuestro territorio y
nuestra cultura
voy a defender el lugar donde enterraron
a nuestros abuelos para seguir esta
lucha junto a las futuras generaciones
a pocos meses de las elecciones
presidenciales este acto adquiere una
fuerte connotación política con la
visita del ex presidente y futuro
candidato de la izquierda luís inácio
lula da silva que prometió revocar todos
los decretos del gobierno de jair
bolsonaro
[Aplausos]
ninguna soldado tiene el derecho de
invadir el espacio indígena en este país
[Aplausos]
ningún brasileño tiene el derecho de
plantar soja ilegalmente o de quemar los
bosques para criar ganado
este país tiene tierra suficiente para
todos
con cantos y bailes los indígenas
intentan presionar al parlamento
brasileño que iba a votar el llamado
paquete de la destrucción un conjunto de
leyes impulsadas por bolsonaro que
amenazan las reservas de marcadas
desde la llegada de este gobierno
sufrimos muchas invasiones
muchos yanomamis han sido asesinados por
mineros más de 24 mil mineros invadieron
las tierras yanomami
las más de 200 niños presentes en
brasilia marchando rumbo al congreso
aunque la votación sea postergada para
una fecha indeterminada quieren
demostrar a las instituciones brasileñas
que no se darán por vencidas y esperan
tener peso en la campaña de las
elecciones presidenciales en octubre de
este año
y vamos a nueva york para revisar la
imagen de la semana la gente corriendo
para escapar de un vagón del subterráneo
de brooklyn lleno de humo tratando de
huir desesperadamente de un hombre
armado que disparó durante la hora pico
dejando alrededor de 20 heridos 10 de
ellos por balas y otra escena por
inhalación del humo el hecho se registró
apenas un día después de que el
presidente estadounidense joe biden
firmara una orden ejecutiva que
endurecerá las normas para controlar los
chips utilizados para montar las
denominadas armas fantasma se trata de
armas caseras sin registro que son
imposibles de rastrear el informe es de
rodrigo sedano
en torno a 20.000 armas fantasma
halladas en eeuu en 2021 cuyas partes
son imposibles de rastrear en la escena
de un crimen hasta ahora porque el
presidente joe biden anunció un nuevo
paquete normativo para elevar el control
de estas y otras armas en eeuu
un delincuente un terrorista un abusador
doméstico puede pasar de un kit de armas
a un arma en tan solo 30 minutos los
compradores no están obligados a pasar
verificaciones de antecedentes porque
las armas no tienen número de serie
desde que la ley se haga efectiva la
justicia perseguirá la fabricación de
estos kits de piezas sin un número de
serie una medida que no ha sido fácil de
alcanzar por la fuerza de los lobbies
armamentísticos
el lobby de las armas trató de atar a
los reguladores y al papeleo durante
mucho tiempo mucho tiempo la asociación
nacional del rifle denominó esta regla
como extrema extrema pero déjenme
preguntarles es extremo proteger a los
oficiales de policía es extremo proteger
a nuestros hijos las autoridades
policiales a nadie sobre el aumento
exponencial de este tipo de armas en
eeuu armas que han sido usadas en
algunas de las más sonadas masacres en
el país mi atleta superviviente del
tiroteo de la escuelas secundarias
august en 2019 estuvo en el acto para
dar fe de ello la medida entra en vigor
en 120 días y desde ya hay
organizaciones que anunciaron que la van
a demandar
vamos a la frontera entre méxico y eeuu
donde muchos solicitantes de asilo
provenientes de ucrania están
enfrentando dificultades y están siendo
regresados a méxico debido al título 42
una ley que permite a las autoridades
migratorias estadounidenses deportar a
personas que vienen de un país afectado
gravemente por el coi 19 los rusos que
no apoyan a vladimir putin están entre
los atrapados veamos más en el informe
de nuestro equipo en terreno
san isidro que se encuentra en la
frontera entre méxico y eeuu es uno de
los cruces fronterizos más transitados
del mundo durante las últimas semanas
tanto rusos como ucranianos se han
reunido allí con la esperanza de llegar
a eeuu
esta familia viajó durante 20 días
seguidos incluso ocho países de europa
esta noche y no fue fácil lloramos mucho
wright
en nuestra ciudad bombardearon dos
aeropuertos y la torre de televisión de
la guerra ha empujado a más de tres
millones de personas a escapar de
ucrania y la mayoría se va a las
naciones vecinas pero cada vez más
refugiados huyen hacia tijuana
anastasia está aquí con su esposa
estadounidense dejó su ciudad natal
kharkiv por la ofensiva rusa
oms mi casa fue bombardeada la casa de
mi abuela fue bombardeada
mi tío fue asesinado por los rusos
después de esperar varias horas los
guardias fronterizos les dicen que
pueden pasar pero a diferencia de los
ucranianos muchos otros solicitantes de
asilo no tendrán tanta suerte nastia
arte ni su hijo vienen de la vecina
rusia
queremos pedir asilo político en estados
unidos somos protestantes y trabajamos
para la iglesia estadounidense en rusia
somos suprimidos y considerados agentes
occidentales
la mayoría serán enviados de vuelta a
méxico antes de que tengan la
oportunidad de pedir asilo gracias a una
ley conocida como título 42 que permite
a las autoridades fronterizas de estados
unidos deportará automáticamente a las
personas mientras esperan la respuesta
de su solicitud como resultado cada vez
más rusos se encuentran varados en
tijuana como agatha y su familia quienes
llegaron a méxico hace más de dos
semanas
afín al líder de la oposición rusa
alexéi navalni la familia optó por huir
del país en lugar de enfrentarse a la
represión y
la guerra la situación política en rusia
ha ido cuesta abajo justo después de que
salimos de rusia putin introdujo una
nueva ley que castigará con 15 años de
prisión a cualquiera que llame a este
conflicto una guerra no puede enfrentar
tal castigo
defensores de los migrantes denuncian
que la medida es injusta ya que no tiene
en cuenta si los solicitantes de asilo
enfrentarían o no abusos contra los
derechos humanos al ser rechazados
también riesgo la vida de las personas
les niega su derecho a protección
internacional
al estar todos varados aquí en la
frontera estamos hablando de miles de
familias
en ciudades tan peligrosas como tijuana
ciudad juárez reynosa están expuestos a
muchísimos peligros también méxico no es
un tercer país seguro que ha puesto en
vigor por primera vez por el presidente
de donald trump el título 42 se ha
utilizado para devolver a más de un
millón de personas a mexico
ahora visitamos el salvador para revisar
la cifra de la semana 10.000 ese es el
número de pandilleros que han sido
arrestados desde que el presidente nadie
busca l activo del estado de excepción
en el país centroamericano el pasado 27
de marzo con el argumento de hacer
frente al aumento en la tasa de
homicidios luego de que se registraran
más de 80 muertes violentas en 48 horas
algunos policías han denunciado presión
para cumplir con las cuotas de arrestos
exigidos por el gobierno mientras que
algunos familiares de los detenidos
denuncian que no eran integrantes de las
pandillas
y esta semana gabriel boric cumplió un
mes al frente de chile al hacer un
balance el mandatario confesó que han
sido 30 días turbulentos las
controversias con su ministra del
interior los ataques de la oposición y
una desconfianza hacia sus propuestas
marcarán los primeros 30 días del
mandato de la izquierdista marta moya
nos cuenta más seamos quienes sean el
gobierno del pueblo indalo sientan como
su gobierno
y
30 días después no es el escenario
idílico que esperaban los votantes y el
propio gabriel boric cuando se posesionó
como presidente de chile el mandatario
más joven de la historia del país del
cono sur cumple un mes al frente del
palacio de la moneda y confiesa que el
aterrizaje fue turbulento la
controversia generada en el ministerio
de interior cuando la ministra izq y así
chest culpó al ex presidente piñera por
la expulsión irregular de migrantes las
tensiones con los mapuches como parte de
un enquistado conflicto entre el estado
los indígenas y las empresas agrícolas y
forestales y los continuos ataques de la
oposición han marcado las primeras
semanas de su mandato que según expertos
no será fácil por la crisis de
legitimidad que atraviesa el país a
todas las escalas esa desconfianza se
rebasa a la élite acá ya tenemos una
crisis de legitimidad de las élites
elite de la iglesia de la política del
empresariado y por lo tanto frente a esa
crisis de desconfianza y por hecho
cualquiera que llegue al poder siempre
van a estar en tela de juicio por parte
de la ciudadanía a una inflación
disparada
en los últimos días las protestas contra
la nueva constitución que se votará el
próximo 4 de septiembre por otro lado
las marchas de cada viernes en los
aledaños de la rebautizada plaza
dignidad kilómetro cero del estallido
social continúan pese a las promesas del
mandatario para quién
no solamente desde el 18 octubre lo que
hace muchos años atrás hemos estado
organizando más en detalle
no hay solución posible con este
gobierno
férreo defensor de la nueva carta magna
para garantizar un cambio estructural
boric tiene que garantizar su aprobación
para legitimar su liderazgo tanto a
escala nacional como en la región
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
giovanni agudelo pueden ver esta emisión
y las anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y envíen sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla para
más información de nuestro continente
sigan viendo france24
[Música]